[Music]
if music be the food of memory as
Shakespeare almost said play on
perfect
treating dementia with musical therapy
is a relatively new idea but one that is
showing promising results
even as we watched 82 year old Jill who
suffers from moderate dementia was
revitalized
I'm just a mum on the own you can't say
that not just anything
children I'm sure I know Sarah two two
yeah Sarah and
Richard
one of each yeah one of each he's lovely
so she I'm sure she I'm sure from a
therapeutic perspective music can touch
emotions unlock memories and the two go
hand in hand really and so positive
memories can just bring somebody alive
reminiscence positive well-being the
engagement in something a meaningful
activity like we saw with Jill playing
the keyboard actually brought back
memories of her children and playing in
the past and the importance of that song
for her
the charity music for dementia has
teamed up with keyboard maker Casio to
launch a unique study using specialized
keyboards they enrolled nearly 200
dementia sufferers in six months of
musical therapy the results Were
Striking 79 of musical therapists saw
improved signs of memory recall in
patients seventy percent saw reductions
in anxiety and depression with projects
such as this one which has been really
Innovative it's been really
collaborative between a care home
provider and a huge part of the music
industry and a campaign we've shown that
it is really possible to make music an
integral part of care where we have
music therapists working in partnership
with carers it's an affordable easy to
roll out program that's it that could be
scaled tomorrow
earlier this year the culture secretary
backed a plan to create a power of music
commissioner to help spread the benefits
of Music in healthcare the challenge for
campaigners will be convincing the
incoming government to play along what a
finish what a finish Matthew Thompson
Sky News